uh I got something for you
I got something for you oh you're gonna
love this one you are gonna love this
one but first of course we need the
intro
oh my God
this is a really good one you're gonna
love it
[Music]
I love my mother
[Music]
so let's get after it and have us
with [ __ ] bread
so good foreign
so let's get after it
Chris Como like his news Nation shows
okay but what I have found is the best
stuff from him is his podcast the Chris
Cuomo project it's a project yes a
project
um I call him I call it the Chris Cuomo
project because I'm always working on
myself you know what I mean we should
all do that let's get after it um why
Thanksgiving is Chris Cuomo's favorite
holiday
it is my favorite
holiday
now
some of you are going to say all right
it's but it's not holiday it's not
religious
who says that nobody says that nobody
says that because I'm not all Veterans
Day is a holiday and it's not religious
Labor Day is a holiday and it's not
religious
Memorial Day
now some of you may say hey Chris this
ain't no holy Bay is he really that's
what he's doing is he literally just
describing what holidays you know most
people don't consider it a real you know
holiday because it's not religious or
anything but uh
the way this man's brain works it's so
dumb fascinating this is great because
he really tries to get philosophical
here in a second it's wonderful to see
let's discuss
interestingly the Eucharist okay the
so you know every single we're about to
get into in here immersion out you're
I'm just going to prepare you so you're
ready
you know whatever you're knowing pagan
it talks about how Christmas isn't
really a Christian holiday oh no wait do
you hear this Guido explain it we're
doing are we doing it's actually
saturnalia and all right but imagine if
Guido saying it
yeah somebody's not a CNN anymore huh
hey is that a dog whistling
[Laughter]
bread we [ __ ] Catholic let's get FB
that Christians uh use Catholics uh most
profoundly as the literal
transubstantiation the changing of
substance of body and blood what does
this have to do with Thanksgiving oh
nothing you'll see what the [ __ ] is
going on hold on he's gonna tell you
wine of Jesus yes Catholics believe
that's what it is hence the end wait
your family's Catholic no [ __ ] way
sense of the spirit and the ringing of
the Bell to Mark the transubstantiation
in the ritual yeah looking at your arms
you're doing some Trend substantiation
Bud why don't we [ __ ] calm down bro
let's relax a little bit buddy
hey look Jesus was all right but did he
have traps like this I don't think so
come on he starts bouncing his his pecs
around
that's what it becomes is he literally
just like is he literally being like all
right no like there's not nothing
nothing thanksgiving's great and all but
I'm pretty sure Christ ain't seen no
turkey so I don't know if I would
consider it a holiday and then what's
gonna happen during Easter is he gonna
go look uh so it's Easter right I want
to talk about the Native Americans and
Christopher Columbus and how we came
together to have turkey with the Indians
and you're like did he does he just not
know which one's which he's so stupid I
love him
for them who would have thought him
getting fired from CNN would only give
us more Christmas oh God it's the best
this is this was actually the better
thing it's the better option much it's
um the story of Labor Day when us
Catholics only had so much oil for one
day but it lasted seven nights Oracle
and you may say that Adam Sandler
cartoon
by the way hey crazy nights are you
making an a crazy nights reference I
hate you [ __ ] off no you're the best the
best part is to his Royce pointed out
it's like oh yeah we get more Chris
Cuomo we don't we not only get more
Chris Cuomo but we get the non-tv
there's no producer in his ear Chris
Cuomo there's nobody going uh wrap it up
Chris can you wrap up the Eucharist talk
you gotta get to commercial break
there's none of that he's untethered
his stupidity his stupidity is
untethered he knows no bounds yeah
there's nobody going we got our heart
out in 30 seconds Chris
oh Chris I love you
oh so glad he's back
whatever look faith is not about the
ability to prove out the reality or
truthfulness of the belief but you
brought this up how about maybe be
thanksgiving's your favorite because you
get a pick on your brother in front of
your mom yeah that's why Thanksgiving is
his favorite
that's not what faith is
hey you stopped being the biggest one a
long time ago
I thought so oh it's so often you need
two camera angles oh God I was about to
make the same thing cause I'm [ __ ]
beautiful
uh he has two biceps doesn't he virgin
looks in the mirror every morning if
only I was a FANUC
it's for his good side and his good side
yeah well that's what I was just going
to say too why do you have two camera
angles because I got two good sides oh
the mystery of Faith anyway the word
Eucharist means he can double check if
he has sauce on his face bro he's still
he's still talking about the Eucharist
Thanksgiving
from the Greek
and it means that this is something that
we are grateful for Jesus's sacrifice in
that context
when I go who's your favorite son she
goes you Chris
like me personally you gotta be grateful
for things you know like me in
retrospect yeah I lost my CNN job but
I'm grateful to be away from that too
you know that FANUC with the [ __ ]
Botox or whatever and the bald guy what
was his name
a little nerd the little Jewish nerdy
guy it's Delta you mean
yeah
so anyway Thanksgiving is about giving
thanks
me
it is sacred what is sacred what is
sacrifice sacrifice is the act of making
something sacred meaning you make it
holy you make it bro oh but there's bro
just say stuffing I mean instead of
going on this why you like it's your
favorite hobby like say you like
stuffing it's fine or like I don't know
if it's Thanksgiving why don't you just
not do a podcast to just go up and
Beauty family no God and we took we took
[ __ ] four days off I'll tell you why
he's not because Thursday's just last
day and he's not missing it for nobody I
get it he don't miss it for nobody you
paused him at Peak thought oh yeah there
he is his brain's about to lose baby I
gotta do my show and then I gotta hit
the Peloton for an hour oh that's the
Danny Saint does do you think do you
know like in cartoons when it goes to
someone thinking it's like gears do you
think when it goes into his brain of
thinking it's just a hand slowly
stirring a pot of sauce
so it's not a holiday it's not no it's
one of those it's one of those like
[ __ ] shitty pizza ovens that you see
in like a Domino's it's a conveyor belt
this is pizza dropping onto it
oh forget about the fact that that's
just way too literal it's just not
accurate why all right let's nobody ask
Chris
conversation with themselves this is so
good this is great I agree with merch
taking the boundaries off of this man
makes it so much better you never he's
never gonna get ah Chris heart out in 30
seconds let's go come on wrap it up bud
come on now I almost said I I got an
idea for a show I'm gonna be the host
and the guest that's why there's two
angles
Chris it's like sometimes it's like you
know I feel like sometimes there's two
wolves inside of me
and both of them like baked ziti am I
right
and both of them are absolute [ __ ]
animals
because I got two good sights
[Music]
one for each good side
I'm too Spirit Wine and Grandpa
this is so I [ __ ] love this are you
kidding me
what are you talking about Jesus's birth
and marking his resurrection and death I
mean what
uh really
that's that's why Christmas is what it
is
some kind of student huh you never heard
of the you never heard of the pagans oh
come on
because that's not what Biblical
Scholars tell us about when Jesus was
born so why is it then convenience and
so that pagans wouldn't kill Christians
so the Christians matched up the timing
of holidays and some of the symbology to
be like a lot of the Pagan look all it's
saying is if I was Jesus they want to
crucify me I'll tell you that right now
okay personally you're talking about me
personally no way I could take two maybe
trees and turns at once
no no
no no rituals that's the Judas gonna be
sleeping with the fish so that the
pagans who outnumbered them wouldn't
kill them
that's not true yes it is
Chris who are you arguing with yeah
you're arguing with yourself
you're arguing with the other wolf and I
know both wolves are [ __ ] I still
you you started this with Thanksgiving
not having anything to do with religion
and he just had been on this weird
religious cake are you okay bud
Jesus Christ
that's why the symbol is a Christmas
tree question where should we get two
free agent shirts
I would yeah
um we get a [ __ ] an angry email from
Rumble what the [ __ ] guys
it's a joke
I have Santa Claus agents inside of me
and they're both looking for work
this is his own thing
inside of me and they're both on
LinkedIn
also can we can I give a shout out to
the blue shirt he had on before they
went live oh yeah and he put up his free
agent shirt over the shirt we gotta sell
the shirt we gotta sell these which why
would I do that I could go to any shop
and lets me print whatever I want and
just type free agent in that font what
is with everybody's lazy t-shirts lately
where it's just a word and black bold
lettering come on man oh yeah what about
Easter though I mean that's when it
happened Easter comes from estrus
he practices in front of a mirror dude
he practices in front of a mirror
there's no way because he's she's trying
to nail these points like they're coming
to his head he practices also you're
making like
college level points right now like
you're making your stone cousin tell me
this is what a snarky kid that came back
from college says at Christmas time to
upset the grandparents Jesus well that's
why there's a Christmas tree you shut
the [ __ ] up Grandma's like 89 years old
maybe let her have one last good
Christmas yes selfish [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
up
saturnalia but break your face and go
with these [ __ ] crystals in the house
I don't like them and if you bring up
any of that butt sex should I swear to
Christ I'll slap Florida I will throw
you out on your ass spend Christmas at
the [ __ ] Roadway Inn [ __ ] out of here
very personal that one the guy fertility
it was Pagan the rabbit and the egg
the hell do they have to do with each
other huh what are you talking about
here what came first how to Rabbit of
the egg that's what I want to know
I bear it no Chris do you think rabbits
are hatched I don't know what am I a
[ __ ] uh some kind of Rapid scientist
what do you call the study of rabbits uh
they are symbols of fertility
and it was lined up with then
again it was more fertile than me yeah
they should have made me the [ __ ]
symbol Out Easter you know
for protection and also power of common
morphology what is it
it'd be so funny if he didn't know how
rabbits were born but he knew the
[ __ ] what the science was called
that's amazing what the [ __ ]
understanding wait you know how to say
that but you think they come from eggs
of ritual
yeah but not like regular eggs colored
ones yeah that's why they they do the
thing for the holiday because they got
the colored eggs why it's called that
that's when it's from so you know he'll
[ __ ] rule all these holidays but tell
him spaghetti's originally from China
he'll [ __ ] punch you right in the
face tell him Christopher Columbus is
anything but a saint he'll kill you yeah
Christopher Columbus was a pedophile
lies into a rage but you make
accommodation I mean that was in [ __ ]
what 1400 and something's like 1492.
statistically he probably was a
pedophile I mean look you you can say
whatever you want about Christopher
Columbus but you say one word about my
mother my
beautiful every time
every time you do that I just think of
the Bobby bottle service yes but my
father
with my father
I love that sketch when he keeps trying
to kiss the woman who's trying to help
catch the guy cheating in
Bobby bottle service was such a piece of
[ __ ] such a good character that always
reminds me every time we do Chris
[ __ ] the circles back to Bobby
bottles there is oh [ __ ] literal okay
empty so Chris complementary breadsticks
straight
Thanksgiving is all of the good things
that we need to inculcate into our sense
of humanity here we go and I love it I
don't love turkey
you [ __ ] love him he's like the best
guy he's just so like there's just
nothing he doesn't
Chris Cuomo
he exists on such a
bass like surface level right right like
there's no depth to him
oh my God he made you something okay
like he has the depth of wax paper
oh [ __ ]
oh
allergies killing me yeah right yeah you
snort you snort a lot of algae medicine
before this Chris I hate when that
happens
uh what did you say what did you say
what did you send me uh oh in the show
like she said I'll go check it out I
wanted him doesn't matter what I got one
of them 30 milligram instant release
allergies
going
I don't know if this is a real movie but
we'll check it out
here we go Let Freedom bada bing the new
film come on
and they're all just colored it's like
wow that movie had the word Fredo in it
like 298 times like you just replace the
n-word with Fredo the whole movie and
it's still Sam Jackson saying it yes
Greg's giving me this look white bread
gray God we like turkey
shut up
nobody is that you be is he being funny
there's no way to tell with him there's
literally that he's like trying to be
funny I mean that's just funny face hey
that's like I know what you're thinking
out there I like Terry shut the [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] degenerate
laughs
you are a turkey I am thankful nobody
likes turkey you [ __ ] [ __ ] we all
know Thanksgiving is just meant to prop
up the turkey industry we all know big
turkey controls it we're not idiots
nobody likes turkey unless it's cold and
part of a sandwich I'm sorry at what
other time of year do you get cranberry
sauce yes it really is just when we dump
off all the foods nobody likes before
they go bad for the year it's like yeah
I just get that
for Greg Ott for Jeff for Rob my rabbit
grin guys you know make one I like
turkey when it's on a sandwich with ham
and roast beef and cheese and a bunch of
other things
it's amazing to me he needs like seven
people to run his one-person show that
he does in his basement so beautiful
the quality so high the look so good
right we're doing this in my apartment
this is in my house I'm grateful for the
opportunity I'm grateful to these guys
they work hard
not grateful for turkey because it
tastes shitty okay I'll eat the dark
meat but we'll try it 100 different ways
it doesn't oh I've heard I've heard that
you're notorious for liking dark meat
yeah I like to eat the dark meat trust
me my dad used to give me [ __ ] about it
all the time he said what are you a
sicilian
um
bring that [ __ ] Mulan around my house
[ __ ] try that [ __ ] around my house
laughs I got a campaign over here